ça c'est un moment difficile la drogue
non non les cheveux là
avant de devenir acteur vous allez
travailler dans la mode non absolument
j'étais mannequin de
81 à 86 alors ce qui est incroyable
c'est que vous allez travailler avec
Dior avec Saint-Laurent channel Chanel
comme Laetitia Casta en fait voilà comme
le petit chien elle est venue après
ouais mais disons que voilà moi je voilà
j'ai été le premier à faire ça
et puis surtout
l'égérie vraiment de de Saint-Laurent et
ça ça a été un grand moment pour moi
dans ma vie de d'homme ou de femme
alors vous bossez énormément vous êtes
vraiment une star et vers la fin des
années 80 c'est la chute
[Musique]
quand vous perdez vos cheveux vous
perdez votre âme et puis perdez beaucoup
de
freiné un matin Pierre Berger vous
appelle vous écoute François tu es chaud
on vend plus une robe tu es viré ouais
carrément viré bah ouais j'étais viré
comme un malproit en même temps j'ai
compris j'ai voulu faire des implants
mais ça marchait pas j'ai fait beaucoup
de rejets et puis voilà on fait ça rien
se passer comme les valets donc je barre
on m'a viré comme un mal propre voilà
donc bah ça a été là c'est là vous êtes
devenu acteur voilà je me suis dit
qu'est-ce que je vais faire donc est-ce
que où je peux m'éclater donc je me suis
dit voilà le métier d'acteur il y avait
peut-être de la place c'était un peu
difficile mais en même temps bon de
Funès c'était mort voilà alors il y
avait une place de une place de comédien
chaud va prendre
j'ai pris des cours de théâtre et puis
bah vous avez du temps à percer quand
même ah oui c'était long en concurrence
a été fait quand même Michel Blanc
Jean-Pierre Bacri Jugnot avec sa
moustache en plus
non j'ai un peu la barbe mais bon par
rapport comme ça s'il vous plaît non
voilà c'est ça absolument c'est quelque
chose mais tout ça c'était je suis
arrivé trop tôt moi
et là vous traversez une période
extrêmement difficile ouais très dur
genre oui parce que
personne ne veut vraiment de moi quoi
donc j'ai fait beaucoup de figuration
je fais du baby-sitting parce que voilà
et hôtesse d'accueil
d'accueil au salon du prêt-à-porter et
au salon de l'auto et au Salon de l'Auto
c'est incroyable voilà je travaillais
pour pour Renault voilà et avant c'était
Skoda même au début tout début c'était
se connaître
en même temps je me suis accroché à
l'époque je crois qu'on peut le dire
vous prostituer
c'était difficile d'aller au début de la
prostitution au début c'est vrai que
c'est pas simple parce que voilà vendre
son corps c'est pas
facile au début et puis finalement
beaucoup de d'amis brésiliens mon
poussé à faire ça donc j'ai fait le mois
de Boulogne le bois de Vincennes le bois
de Boulogne tout ce qui était travelo
donc plutôt la Grande Cascade
depuis bon ben voilà je vous ai
rencontré Patrick Sébastien Patrick
Sébastien
et donc il m'a beaucoup aidé
enfin voilà financièrement
vous inscrivez au Front national
un parti alsacien très traditionnel
et là votre carrière d'école vous
enchaînez les rôles de avec un
bonheur absolument incroyable
j'aime bien jouer les les
sabots tout ça etc
bah oui parce que forcément j'avais je
savais comment on faisait
alors là dans Momo vous faites votre
retour au théâtre avec Muriel Robin ça
se passe comment
c'est compliqué enfin je pensais pas que
ce serait comme ça c'est un peu
compliqué
jalouse je sais pas
amoureux
en même temps je ne sais pas c'est bien
possible
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu